we're wanting to do is make solid
incremental steps on trade
the biden administration is not doing
free trade deals uh around the world
right now but i've got absolutely every
confidence that a great deal is there to
be done and there are plenty of people
in that
building behind me who certainly want to
do one
let's bring in our political editor beth
rigby who has been following the prime
minister in the united states currently
in washington beth let's talk about this
issue of the northern ireland protocol
and president biden's issue with it is
it a bit of a ruse is joe biden really
that concerned about it or is it the
fact that he doesn't want or need a
trade deal with the uk
well so jane i think it's
a bit of both really look let's just uh
sort of zoom out a bit the fact is that
brexit one of the big so it's windy here
my hair's getting my way uh in terms of
brexit uh the big
selling point by boris johnson was this
great us uk free trade deal we heard so
much about it and now here he is in
washington and it has been kicked very
much into the long grass the prime
minister making it clear that it isn't a
priority uh for president biden although
he did say president biden that they
were still talking in the white house
yesterday in the oval office and when i
asked him yesterday about well can you
get it in your first term as prime
minister by 2024 he simply cannot commit
to that because he doesn't know
if he can so that really is on a back
burner there was some positive news for
the prime minister this morning though
they are going to lift the ban on
british lamb he's talked a lot about the
ban on british beef being lifted and
president biden name checked that in the
oval office yesterday so something for
boris johnson to hold on to but then yes
on the issue of the northern ireland
protocol joe biden made no secret of the
fact he's no fan of brexit he's an irish
american president he's very concerned
about what's going on with the protocol
you know about this now all of those
problems about the trade between
northern ireland and great britain
checks disruption uh the european union
saying that the uk won't implement the
protocol as agreed the uk saying the
protocol isn't workable as they agreed
it so this is a problem that is not yet
resolved and i would argue that it is a
shadow over this relationship with
president biden boris johnson boris
johnson said
that the on on camera this morning that
the president didn't mention this in
that 90-minute bilateral very strange
because the actual official readout from
downing street says the exact opposite
it says the prime minister updated
president biden on developments with
respect to the northern ireland protocol
since they last met in june when it was
raised at the g7 the leaders agreed the
importance of protecting peace in
northern ireland so the idea that this
isn't an issue for the us is just simply
not true
beth can we talk about france now
obviously france still furious about
being cut out of the security pact
between australia the united states and
the uk and the prime minister seems to
be trying to smooth the waters by saying
there could be a way in for them
yes sergeant there's been a development
on france this morning the prime
minister for days because we've been
asking him has been at pain to be very
careful not to agitate the french to
talk about the deep friendship to try
and reassure
paris that this
trilateral agreement between the us the
uk and australia to provide
supply nuclear submarines to australia a
big strategic area
for those three countries in the
indo-pacific very
keen to stress to the french that this
is not cutting them out that this
doesn't affect relations but let's have
a listen uh to what the prime minister
said this morning words that i don't
think will go very uh down very well in
paris let's listen to what he had to say
i just think it's it's it's time for
some of our dearest friends around the
world to you know prone and grip
about all this uh and don in one hand
break
because this is
fundamentally a a great step forward for
global security uh it's three very
like-minded allies standing shoulder to
shoulder creating a new partnership for
the sharing of technology
i mean in terms of the prime minister's
words there the kind of give me a break
in french
i think it will irritate uh paris uh he
has been as i said so careful
diplomatically uh for days but words
there uh that will perhaps irritate an
already very sensitive france